[ __ ] still sweat over here all laugh
welcome to the I love podcasts and the
Lords of gaming dotnet episode number
109 and it's another glorious Sunday
we're back at the roundtable and the
Lord's Day I'm very excited about our
special guests and we've got ps5 secret
sauce epic store acquisitions games as a
service valve ER and Borderlands three
revealed to discuss so we gonna get
right into it I want to introduce a Lord
whose knowledge and passion for consoles
truly resonates as a seasoned member of
our gaming community this Lord
consistently promotes a platform of
professionalism and always has fun while
continuing to represent the good in
gaming reducing the hosts of the big
cast podcast and founder of seasoned
gaming comm the Lord of Porsche power
and representative of all games all
platforms no ads no BS live from Kansas
City and making his day
into the realm of the Lord's mom made
Lord
Angley Bowden how you doing sir I'm
doing real well man how you guys doing I
don't think anyone's gonna top that
intro absolute pleasure to have you
today been talking about this for weeks
and I had this tornament come up I
couldn't get out of its a big thing here
and they accommodated my schedule and I
just want to thank you guys for fusili
so sorry to hold it up no no for we've
been thanks for making it man you can
come late any time you let you bring
into statues I love this right here yeah
bet what have you been playing sir man
what games are you IMPLAN oh man well I
finished up Sakura finish that and I
played the hell out of Division two I'm
a big loser shooter
so I'm already kind of maxed you know
I'm like gear score 510 or I'm kind of
maxed out there and then right now I've
been all about Mortal Kombat I'm a big
Mortal Kombat guy you guys like white
it's a fantastic version man oh it is
crazy
I've got a Raiden and a sub-zero statue
- I almost brought those today but I
don't know I like these oh man what
y'all gonna have to do it like a joint
show you and Kay
listen I have no problem and I said the
evolution of this of the channel for
king of statues is being on other
people's were you know residents and
checking out their collections and
that's what I'm talking about that's the
evolution of the channel now yo already
all salute Lord dead singer thank you
brother 10 I'm a super chat salute to
the Lord salute - Lord Phil Dominus this
will be a fantastic show as always
stellar amazing grant strategy game that
o stellaris that is granting every
multi-player due out 15th of May you
plug in for still are you a rep for
stellaris what's good over here
well did you put a super chair we got a
lot of show thank you but you did what
did you play pants and pesos the money
currency Aynsley in the rome taking his
statue game straight to king of the
original game of next level gaming had a
great Sega show with him man please
check that out all say the memories will
face second boy for life likewise man
that's my guy right there
so let's get into and of course we have
a Lord that is no league reaming
brethren but a true friend to the entire
realm of the ILP although not frequently
seen enough
this Lord's high quality videos it's
smooth radio friendly delivery
completely evoke real passion from
hardcore gamers everywhere
introducing the panelists of the RDX
podcast and the co-host of the fight
culture podcast Captain neutral himself
and the only Lord who voted Steve
Buscemi as the face of the live-action
sonic movie
laughs from the bay making his return to
the realm of the lord's mommy Lord J
Fonzarelli how you doing sir
I'm doing great and you have the best
introductions ever ever so and I'm
humbled anyways I'm glad to be here no
doubt man good to have you back man
thanks for holding us down true friend
to the row hit my man file he said Cobb
I got you what you've been playing sir
I've been playing that I've been fraud
okay because I was talking negatively on
this game for a while seeing the
previews not feeling it honest opinion
on it saying you know it doesn't look
like it's for me I tried it and I
actually really liked it a lot despite
all of its flaws because there's a lot
of it days gone yes yes my god I love
your videos right there you'll shout out
the Lord meds in the building he says my
co-host the fight culture so what's
going over cuz give us a quick sir now I
don't want blow up your show cuz I know
what's the show gonna go down so you
gonna break it down with you immense
what time show right after that right
after this show or at 1:00 we're gonna
do it at 1:00 p.m.
West Coast time so I may dip out a
little early go do my show we're gonna
talk about mixed martial arts what
happened last night
all the news of the week can't wait man
a fantastic card that I miss I'm
definitely gonna be tuning in not live
but obviously I still gonna cash in a
shot Lord may its absolute pleasure so
yo fight culture podcast off your MMA
guys please check these guys out on that
fantastic show so here we go and of
course we got the original four horsemen
well actually three horsemen went down
or horsemen salute Lord soft taking care
of family business hopefully we will get
him back so brother we miss you and
definitely always a pleasure to have you
in the realm but we still have my
co-host with the cold most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror and mommy Lord addict
doing pretty good I like this this too
crazy the mate was crazy
well what's doing
Wiggin out wave you gotta tell me what
it's doing dictionary I don't know if
you guys ever but maybe he's maybe it
was the game that he's playing he's
playing you know you addict don't listen
to the podcast
he's just see them my needs
my my needs to be pushed in like five
different directions to be able to focus
okay just you know I'm reaching for that
you know it's been a good week but good
playing this game fell so it's people
that all studio sir let's plug them sir
yeah it is by six I studio nice man met
those guys not this years past was a
last year's back fax much to both of
them cuz I saw her and went to the
studio under 1c entertainment right yes
yeah it's it's pretty much a spiritual
successor or Final Fantasy Tactics hmm I
I will say that you know they have a lot
of different aspects that that are in
like tactics like they even have certain
classes have the exact same abilities
that tactic says but uh you know it's
one of those things that they did take
some things from from the games that
they work cuz he was very open with he's
like yeah he's like it definitely you
know might have looked at uh might have
played a tactic here there it's
definitely a good game I enjoy it on the
story feels like it's about to come to a
conclusion and then something else
happened so like oh okay
right so I guess there's another ten
hours of gameplay gotcha
definitely good game that's what's up
man so has been all fail Co all day you
finally off the second roll yeah yeah
I'm just waiting for you to get that
uninstalling so I actually put it to
rest just like oh my god and of course
we have the Incredible Hulk of this aka
the XS game ooh the lord of combat
sports
king of the statute i'll know about
today doh
Premium experience it is the leader of
the fraud alert movement Oh beloved Lord
King how you doing sir I'm doing
fantastic again I like to give a shout
out to Canelo for doing the thing and I
like to give a shout out to Danny Jacobs
it's played you saw last night brother
when opportunity knocks when you have
the ability to seize your own future and
you don't kick that door down and slam
it to the floor and throw it into the
bushes we don't grab the bull by the
horns and push forward you my friend or
loser that play it safe that hold my
coin and I told you to listen to your
train to see the naughty girl off him
got rid of his trainer for financial
reasons right and I think that's a
sucker move all right this is real man
talking you talk early on it's okay yes
you go to the dance for the people that
got you there you know third in a good
day I mean a bad day so it's gonna be
good in the great days right so he signs
a big check and he ditches his coach
over financial reasons got you now what
you don't do is you don't ditch your
coach you don't ditch the guy that got
you to the dance with nobody want to
dance with your ugly behind all right
what you do is you add on you add pieces
this is Lego blocks right you wonder if
you want to increase your stack of bread
that's coming in you don't want to
decrease it right so now you looked at
as the bad dude that's Donati golonka
yesterday Danny Jacob went into a
different direction I told you all on
combat talk if he decided to jab and
play it safe and look for his
opportunities it was never gonna show up
Canelo has turned into the Floyd does
the the Mexican Floyd Mayweather do I
did catch some of it in his head
movement brother he he there was one
round I seen him dip dive then do the
slip I was like yeah I didn't know Dawg
he could never have that kind of defense
he stayed in pocket you saw it right you
stay literally in front of Jacobs men
slip dip slip slide moved his head over
and was still cognizant enough to throw
overhand right hand that landed and he's
kept out of it and pivoted road and his
Jacobs was the bigger man correct yes
he's the bigger Longer more athletic guy
in the fight and I felt that he didn't
presses with his advantages I'd also
thought his corner was giving him bad
information when your fighter looks you
lost in his eyes and he tells you what's
the score then you know when I asked
that part I understand what's going on
in the pit inside his stomach and he
asked him what's the score and he said
it's close
ma you don't need to push put your foot
on the gas mm that guy needs to be fired
that guy needs to be replaced as your
head because right now you're in a fight
of your life everybody was sitting there
saying what is he waiting for
every time he landed a good punch he
shook his head like looked at Canelo
like see I can do that too um then you
really didn't believe that you can
actually win yeah shut up
Canelo and you know I guess no problem I
was on and his leg and Camilla's having
a great time Oh quainter I did this week
played myself I played myself had a
choice money came in shadow you know my
Microsoft money came in so I went down
the game stopped the old good old way
and I let me further put you guys in the
bushes by buying Microsoft credit money
yeah here's this and now I'm not buying
nothing out of your store I'm gonna owe
you weight and got digital yes and I'm
going back home and I'm gonna spread my
money where I want to spread it down
I'll respect that I respect that so
that's pretty much what it's been for
you this weekend no dude so just what I
purchased was money all right I purchase
I could have brought Mortal Kombat I
even got a Playstation did you money got
Dave's going to me I really wanted to
buy purchase World War Z
interesting
okay thank you dealer thank you I'm
gonna say thank you dealer for putting
me in this corner with this game this
game so far played a little bit know you
know when you purchase a game you got
their face spiritual successor to like a
left for dead like Oh [ __ ] to be real
what's wrong but don't you like about it
guns like no in the zombies you shoot
them in the toy precise headshots I feel
that whole part right to put the most
polygons I've ever seen in my life on
your screen without chugging and turning
into a mess I don't know how they doing
it but the lighting effects look good
everything looks good I just the guns
don't feel no vods of this say you kept
the operation of Raccoon City face oh I
added shout-out to jamya Dixon he just
bought fail seal off your recommendation
oh that's what's up brother that's what
Sevilla great gave you a Final Fantasy
Tactics guy that is your thing I've
never seen addict so I addicts giving it
to see liberal trust me is it you know I
gotta say David you bought the wrong one
you should have got days gone then I
felt like that that's the same thing I
said in my head you know you know when
you're old fraud alert going on and you
already spend your money you can't get
out of it you dirty lot of so many has
been kings
of course we have the Lord of the
cooperative experience in himself
there's no be Laura Cognito spreading
that realness in the realm of the IOP
not telling you what you want to hear
but what you need to hear for me it's
just been mortal
that I actually got back on a destiny to
a little bit division a little bit just
like little bits and pieces here and
yeah man right now Borderlands I finally
own king remember we went to packs I
find order to do that download so I did
I got a question for you borderline
hardcore guys like I don't know which
one to start should I start the
pre-sequel in 4k with the HDR no allowed
only acts or should I start the other by
part one enhance so more let's put that
in the chat for me let me know what
should I introduce myself to the series
I played two before I only play a little
bit of it well it started together let's
play it was like me and we'll play it
together
I find it a snoozefest oh my lord it's
got alright no bad says I should play
the pre-sequel alright so I might start
with the pre-sequel then what's going on
sir alright that's all we got so now
that we got to what the Lord's our plan
I want to start with Lord
Bowden his video game system history and
what led him to create the bit cast in
his journey as a journalist for the
fence founder of season gaming calm so
Lord
Bowden let's start from the very
beginning what was some of the first
video game systems you had and what got
you in the game Wow real early Atari
2600 um when I was four started playing
and by time I was about five six I was
already beating my older brother and
sister and those games so I grew up with
Atari and then you know you get to about
six seven years old and I remember
walking into a Woolworths I'm gonna give
that a shot the NES for the first time
you know set up and that kind of blew me
away and couldn't afford it at the time
but I went over to a buddy's house a
couple months later he had him we played
Mario and when you play more when you're
our age and you play Mario Brothers for
the first time it was a revolutionary
experience so started there and ever
since then nothing but games man it's
always been a passion of mine I've owned
I won't say every console cuz there's
hundreds right but I mean damn near
every console you could name I've owned
I've been part of a neo geo collector
scroll drinking alike what happened oh
you out fanboy you know we got these two
yeah man I so you know 16-bit eras my
damn I love Super Nintendo and Genesis I
was a second kid man I had a Master
System
now you gotta give me like two Master
System games though of your favorites if
you can yeah sure I'm sure sure so I
actually liked the original Rambo which
is a weird call out yep great game great
game the original Ghostbusters on there
was that different that was a good game
outruns a classic and then I'm a
die-hard RPG guy so phantasy star i mean
that's was so the original will original
fans the lists and you had all man I
still remember the music in the team oh
man dude I've got a cooking Becker like
fine art print of the fantasy star one
off the Senate Victor it's beautiful and
I still have my original copy from when
I was ten years old sitting on a shelf
Wow continued to progress oh wow so then
you know 90s teenagers started you know
girls cars what-have-you right so a
little a little less time for for games
but uh ps1 came out I was a Dreamcast at
launch I can still remember going into
KB to voice buy a Dreamcast launch and
then in my early 20s I got in an innie
ojio group I was back on the East Coast
right outside of Philly that's where I
lived growing up and I got into a neo
geo group in Maryland and build a custom
Neo Geo MVS cabinet that you could hook
up to TVs with joysticks and I collected
those and I started buying in trading
games you know on eBay when he babe was
first coming up yes and then after that
man then you had the original Xbox in
2001 and GameCube and Xbox and halo-halo
is my favorite
so I said that was revolutionary man
when I is that it ODST shirt sir is that
oh of course man in card today
I always repay low in one way or another
it's everywhere man I have hallo
everything he's certified out here King
you hear this talk told you when he
jumped on I said oh and you got the ODST
repeat game a long time ago once it had
the two statutes on the side now first
of all that Prime one statue is very
legit the Peale went uh out of
production
I think it was like in a couple of hours
yeah you gotta be quick on the draw with
these things Lord De Niro primero said
for master system but how far did you
get in my hero remember to take a card
was endless loop of pain everything it
was hardest element they don't like
games like that anymore
oh my god yeah yeah so I did own that
game at one point me too yeah yeah so
anyway that xbox i halo and then I was
an xbox live beta tester I still have my
shirt might get from the beta testing
xbox live in 2002 so if you look at my
profile like you know it uh it's the
highest number you can get you know for
years I'm like you would say I think was
he last well you the 15 or 16 yeah I
actually wrote a long article on a 15th
anniversary last year highlight in the
history of all of Xbox Live from the
beginning to now so anyway and then you
know the last couple years go for
themselves ride ever since ps2 and Xbox
and then up through 360 was amazing and
then I've just I've become a real big
collector over the past eight years
so I mean literally this entire basement
is just again it's my game room there's
oh you got Kingdom it's endless yet you
buy the lead that what I'll be about do
rolls over about tremendous history man
Wow Wow what what it is so I want to
break it down now to the creation of the
big cast like yeah yeah the team Lord
Burch signs I believe what Dan Rodriguez
and I wanted also I want you to talk
about that creation how that started and
then also that little funny thing you
guys do a back seat game and taste got
hilarious so break down the bit cast out
of that sort yeah so a couple years ago
I found myself talking about games every
day as we most of us do right and I was
chatting on some social media with games
every single day and I'm like everyone
just kept saying you know you know so
much about games you have such a history
with them and you talk every day about
him on you put that to use so I just
started a blog back in 2016 just myself
writing some [ __ ] out you know and then
I was like you know I want to put a
little effort into this and I turned it
into the site so I I created and code
the psyche myself I run it and then um
Bert is an old friend of mine we've been
friends for a long time he's down in
Austin and I was like hey would you want
to you know contribute to some of this
and so he started getting involved and
we created the channel and then we just
started playing around with podcasting
and some of our as we probably all
experienced some of our early podcaster
hilariously bad from you know about that
we have a couple big cats that are not
published was another number one debuted
I met Dan through Twitter actually you
know a bunch of us on Twitter chat and
found out he lives like 15 minutes from
me though
so we started talking one day became
friends and then I invited him on and
he's become a regular so the goal for
season gamo is really you know I think
you probably noticed I don't try to get
involved in any of the shenanigans and
nonsense and BS man I just love talking
about games and the history of woman so
that's where the season gaming came from
and just you know wanted to put
something out there I know there's a
million podcast and there's so many good
ones you know so it's not even really
about creating anything crazy we just
love talking about games that's all
that's all where it came from
oh love the purity of it sir fantastic
in the backseat game with these pretty
funny drug
that's a little bit out I think yeah
that was our take on like a let's play
so Dan actually comes over here we
record in my basement here and then
Bert's down and in Austin and we just
take turns playing a game with the other
two just give it up [ __ ] basically why
it's gone no that's what's up gree
history there now wanna briefly touch
also on this masterpiece of yours and I
call it see that amazing article the
good in gaming and I got a chance to
check that out and I want to say start
off that it really resonated with me as
a person who definitely just cope into a
loss of a close friend as you see shot
my boy Lord whiskey and I know you've
been through a huge you know thing deal
with your son proton just touchy-feely
you know I wasn't to talk about the
positive aspects of it and um give me
some inspirations about like how gaming
affected you in you know what inspires
you to make that article yeah so yeah so
for those are unaware and I'm not trying
to turn the big cast a little sour here
but last year my my 17 year old son was
killed it was the day after e3 so I flew
I flew home for me3 and I was obviously
hype there's my first e3 and I got home
he went out that follow one night and
didn't come back rest in peace
thank you so anyway in thank you so you
go you know you go through a serious
reflection right me and my wife and
think it's gonna happen so kind of was
out of the loop for a couple months and
then I started just when I slowly
started playing games again it became a
bigger relief you know it's always an
escape but um it became something new
that it hadn't felt like before and then
I started to thinking back to the days
of playing in the arcades and Mortal
Kombat the original and - and Street
Fighter and how you kind of built that
camaraderie with the people the regulars
that you would see every day I'd walk to
the mall man with my quarters and you
know put a quarter up and and you play
play tournaments I played Street Fighter
and Mortal Kombat tournaments and just
that group of guys and the thing I love
about gaming is when you look at that
scene today it's more like Evo right so
if you look at the competition scene the
thing I love about it more than anything
else is that you can look across that
and the playerbase and it doesn't matter
how old you are doesn't matter what you
look like I come from what your
background is but none of that matters
man it's all about the gaming and your
talent level and I love that I think
that gaming has brought people together
of different cultures and backgrounds
and races and sexes for decades and I
don't think it's got enough credit for
doing that and only the people like us
who are in it see it that way right
hopefully so you know I just I went out
there and I was like you know what I'm
tired of hearing all the bad things
about gaming this is this is you know
this is bullcrap there's there's a lot
of good things that gaming does and so I
started doing my research and most of
the articles that I write take me a
while to write because I do a lot of
research before I put the words down and
I'm very picky about how I write I do
revisions like 10 sometimes and so it
took some time but you know I research
charities my research companies like
Extra Life and gamers outreach and
scientific studies of people who use
gaming for escapism and depression and
overcome anxiety so again our community
not to cut you in and that's why it
really resonated with me because again I
just lost my friend
and it's like you say like the mental
health issues that the depression that's
in our community and it there is this
case if there's so many positive aspects
of gaming that help us deal in our
normalizes it helps you get away so a
really resently I thought that was an
excellent point yeah thank you yeah yeah
no I mean I think most of us agree right
and I just wanted to put it out there
and I shared it and it got shared kind
of all over which was excellent I've I
still I wrote that up when did I write I
don't know it's been four or five six
months now when I put it out there and I
still get feedback today people will DM
me or email me or you know what have you
and reach out and just say man this
really touched me this really I'm just
going to tear it out to the chat right
now for those who don't know about it
it's a fantastic article it's in the
chat y'all look good in gaming please
check that out man thank you brother oh
man so such a positive thing and these
are the things that we like to celebrate
and arm
like I said I really appreciate you your
openness and your honesty with that that
was amazing the research you did was
tremendous it took a lot to do and I
want to make the point clear you know I
didn't want someone to read it and come
back and say yeah but gaming's minik you
know we're gonna make this clear it's
those good things you know we're not
there's no debate to be had here exactly
y'all ready and of course last point I
want to make arm recently the Lord of
Esquire magazine come to find out that
they voted you the third most famous
Ainsley how well the number one Ainsley
in gang right we go to number three so
talk about that that article have been
recognized by Esquire Tom it's great you
know what's funny about that is I post
you know I posted about we joked about
it and someone else reached out to me
and it's like hey Ainsley you know it's
not just Esquire your names all over the
place and they sent me like four more
links to UK publications with voting me
so yeah me and my buddies you know I'm
dead there and dinero we I'm on there um
shared show on third wheel arcade too
and I'm always undead and to do yeah
yeah yeah we kind of we take turns we
chat everyday and uh it's become almost
a running joke at this point because
what happened right is because you know
I'm just involved in this daily right so
I've got my ear to the ground I know a
lot of people that talk about technical
specs and my career my professional life
is very technical orientated to
application development and so on yeah
so I mean I'm involved in you know I'm
interested in the cloud architecture and
artificial intelligence and BOTS and all
this stuff right so I'm just always kind
of reading this tech stuff and so I've
kind of got my ear to the ground when
the new consoles are being developed
because that's what it's all about it's
technology and so anyway I was just
in a statement yeah ps5 sounds great I'm
excited about it and you know from what
I've heard from the people I talked to
and the things I've seen anaconda you
know that the higher level next Xbox is
going to be even stronger
yeah and hell man it wouldn't it went
everywhere I don't even I don't like to
work Jesus yeah you took I want you to
do it because I'm gonna revisit that but
get to the secret sauce talk that but I
definitely definitely respect you I saw
I saw thought of God thought it was
really cool man but you got some
recognition in that respect what we ask
all the guests here at the roundtable
Lord about and I meet those top five
video games or franchises of all time
your personal choice now I'm assuming
one is with church got all let's go are
we talking favor to what I think is kind
of favorite / best oh let's go with your
personal favor your whatever it is even
if it affected affected you the most
yeah I gotta be halo halo see for sure
it's gotta be game was revolutionary
right I think a bunch of us can call out
the Goldeneye in the n64 days yes and
that was about what my friends were in
college and I wasn't when Halo came out
and it took everything to the next level
right and so from there that changed my
course guys started playing Halo
tournaments and being involved in Xbox
community and I play Halo 2 tournaments
and Xbox Live and so yeah I think halo
has got to be my personal top one nice
all right so we got we got halo yeah and
um Witcher 3 whoo
that's why Carol's here sitting with me
I think Witcher 3 is probably this is
just my opinion but you know this I
think it's probably the greatest game
ever made mmm it's uh it's just uh
things that are just unmatched there is
so much that's unmatched mm that's
what's stuck so we got we got hail
got which it alright give me three more
got a Bioshock you know why he's ready
listen listen listen first of all he's a
ringer
alright I'm came in fresh off the hockey
game right he slid up and listen he
already had to set up already
alright he said he knew one he was gonna
be late right so he said okay let me
have my setup already so he's not fixing
things as he got in to he already knew
what shirt he was gonna put on alright
because he was representing ODST right
three he had the both statues dead now
I'm telling you guys what you don't
really understand is I'm pretty sure he
has more statues there but he very
specifically knew that he was gonna put
each of those statues there so when he
was given his top five I knew for a fact
that one was gonna be with you and two
was gonna be by your shop because
physically placed them man now remember
he told you in his articles he has to do
it three or four times that's right
so that means he's a strategist and his
planning is definitely at the utmost can
you tell you sir about halo we got
Witcher and Bioshock yeah more to round
it off
yeah Last of Us for sure oh wow this is
hard this is strongly Last of Us you
know the gameplay I want you guys to
look over his left shoulder alright
[Applause]
so this this man was sitting here
talking about he was born in 78 well I
was born in 75 you know I'm a little
older nice he's going through all these
consoles yeah I had that I had that the
only one I didn't have was the Neo Geo I
go this guy's emulating my life and then
he comes out with this top five listen
like he's got the Last of Us
halo combat Evolved and Red Dead 2 on
there three of my five so yes this man
he's got it he's got with him deciding
that steelbook and I got a signed
picture over there hung up too but he's
a real nice guy man I think Arthur
Morgan is one of the greatest
protagonists and you know his breath the
best and you know what as soon as I beat
that game I I sent a DM to Roger Clark
and he responded he was very an that a
little chat it was great I gotta bail
him all right because right now he's
playing a simulation he's on the reels
and he's just I gotta be real you take
you down a lane you probably was ready
for but what was your first statue
why did you collect it and what is your
latest peel great question so my I got a
buddy who's more like you he has tens
and tens and tens of comic statues I'm
huge collector and so I saw some Hayes
in real life and once you first see him
in real life you understand right like
they are something different like people
are like are like action figures like
that's fine because once you start
collecting like these are just something
else man and so the first one I got was
all for him he got me into it and I have
a Punisher Matt kicked a one two six
original Punisher the original Frank you
talk about the white one with the white
with with that white chest and the boots
the oh no the McCain the maquette is
now I know the one you're talking about
now this is what he's standing there
he's got the gun off he's got the shells
all around his feet all right yeah oh
yeah it's on the shelf
I should have brought it out but that's
the first one ever got it he sold it to
me it's worth about 800 to 1,000 he sold
it to me for 400 and just to get me into
it and funny enough the second one I
bought was the very well-known Hellboy
from I forget the guys name now the
artist named Mike something I think
right but anyway beautiful statue I
still have them both actually those are
the only two comic ones I have
everything else our gaming statues and
the latest one I got is this Bioshock
one but I have trysts from Witcher 3 on
the way that was my question do you find
yourself like okay I go down a line like
the Holy Trinity I put up the Holy
Trinity and I got the early Holy Trinity
and I got the second Holy Trinity going
up if you guys don't understand what I'm
talking about when I say Holy Trinity
I'm talking about DC's Holy Trinity
which is Superman Batman and Wonder
Woman all right and it's a reason why
that is then I will go into that later
on but this is a king of the statue is a
slightly interrogation um do you find
yourself looking for the next in that
line because I noticed
- it's hard Tricia's next and there's
another secret piece that Prime one
didn't put up yet uh do you find
yourself looking for that and you do you
plan out your space absolutely
absolutely so I've got Tris add ciri on
the way pre-ordered both exclusives Tris
is my girl so you know you can get you
can get yennefer her as well for those
which are fans out there but I kind of
skipped on that one but I have a whole
Witcher 3 section of my gaming room over
there with Jarrell I have all the Dark
Horse figures I have prints all over
there but I've got Tristan Syria on the
way and yeah you have to play it because
we were talking before we went live
right these things aren't like you have
to plan the where they're gonna be and I
have special shelves kind of around and
whatnot so I got chief over there and
some other ones
but yeah Marty I'm already thinking man
where's trisko and so I'm gonna mess
with I'm like a choice has to be next to
girl right so I'm gonna make dude thank
you I appreciate it thank you so much I
love a little bout we got a lot of show
we gonna get into but um don't end this
five man oh wow that was I was insane
so last week's poll results are in and
people have spoken the question with all
the recent leaks rumors and speculation
regarding the 2019 Microsoft press
conference which rumor do you think is
most likely to come to pass the winner
at 36% and a razor close
four-way IOP vote is the Xbox will have
another studio acquisition group coming
in at second at 33% was the Xbox girl or
where announced group in a razer coaster
that 19% was the new Splinter Cell
announcement game announcement group and
in last place and only 12% was Xbox is
in the bushes if there's no I new IP
shown all the over 200 that he'll
participated or what am i first of all
see do we have loads in the bus we do
that is that our guide Lord of tech you
know was good of a gadget you convey
gourmet all that tremendous surprise to
have you in the realm so we had the poll
the Lords have voted Lord mods the arm
that they think that Xbox gonna have a
studio acquisition what do you think is
that the more guaranteed thing what do
you think well I mean from the rumors
and stuff like I'm sure they they will
have at least one right and we all know
it's no secret that Microsoft is looking
for more so I guess it's not really a
question of if they going to have any
studio acquisitions by but really how
many but know
fair enough got thanks to all the lords
who voted and participated no Fonz do
you think you've let me get your yeah
they're gonna pick up a tiger electronic
so you know those handhelds were fired
no if they don't have new IPs yeah
they're in the bushes yeah I feel you
man they need to get some new IPs going
so shout out to all the lords vote it
will have a new one cooking up we're
gonna get into this table shell we got a
lot to discuss so I'm had I guess said I
had to bring in the Lord of tech and a
fan favorite
Lord mods and uh we're gonna talk about
the source y'all we gonna talk about
this getting the four heart shot because
of a heart check y'all Merc 305 what's
going on man good to see some faces in
here absolu SaLuSa we gonna talk about
the source so it all started obviously
with our CNBC I believe AMD CEO Lee
Sassoon he discussed the partnership
with Sony teasing them about the text
fear about what they're doing and she
made a statement that got the text we
all rattled up she said we are honored
and proud to be part of Sony's next
generation PlayStation this has been a
really long-term partnership with them
we love gaming we dig gaming is a really
good secular growth market and then
basically she talked about arm she said
what we have done with Sony architecture
is really something special and for
their application their special sauce he
says a great honour for us we're really
excited about what the next generation
station will do so I want to break this
topic into two parts in the first part I
want to talk about the tech about what
we know so far the latest rumors in the
hardware and then part two we will break
down the X Factor and what can Scarlett
do to compete so part one the sauce
Lord God let's start with you sir um
what is going on what are you hearing
and I'm saying and then also I want to
talk about your theory with the embedded
SS SSD that you got going that beautiful
article on Lords of gaming that net plug
plug plug
yeah okay well first of all nobody
really knows what this whole secret
sauce is all about to be honest with you
because you just you should have gone
first then like Barry Bonds oh no I mean
like listen there's no there's no such
thing as secret sauce per se right it's
not it's there's nothing that for
example Sony could come up with that
would really surprise anyone I mean
we're talking about technology that is
pretty much sort of a variable already
right so I think the whole secret sauce
is really more about this specification
of these chips and all these
customizations that obviously you know
we keep hearing about is you know these
customization has more to do with for
example you know improved latency with
for example you know size of the cache
because we know that you know that
whether that's GPU CPU the more cache
you've got the better performance you
know normally you get right things like
you know memory bandwidth and also all
kinds of like new features because like
you know like if you if you look at like
if you look at Vega for example play
when PlayStation 4 Pro launched it came
out it came with these double use of of
16-bit float right which helps a little
bit in terms of performance so I guess
we could we could call it our
PlayStation 4 Pro secret sauce as well
right so I think this is what we
actually really talking about speaking
about the secret sauce and also I don't
really want to make this too long but
last one thing about above this top
secret sauce and the actual Navi because
this is actually a known fact that when
AMD was working still on Vega right you
know after after they released polaris
to Vega was obviously was always
intended as a server and more
professional kind of card right so it's
very computer heavy so it's very good in
calculations that kind of but it's not
necessarily so good
in other tasks like more related to
gaming like geometry for example one of
the biggest improvements of that Vega
was supposed to have was improved a
geometry engine right so it was supposed
to be no process more of the geometry in
that case I think it's called like you
know primes or something like that I
would have to go back to some of the
articles I read in the past but it
sounds like that so for example current
GCN architecture allows for one geometry
engine per clock
you know process like four or five of
these primes right while they were
planning to increase it like 11 or
something that right which so basically
right now DC and with GCN architecture
the geometry engine is a big bottleneck
so I think and right now I'm hearing
that with Navi they are working on
actually improving that as well so I
think that's basically so co2 confirm
mr. this soil here's here's the thing I
believe this is a lot like when they
talked of rapid pack math you know it's
just you know optimus you know
optimizations and that's basically all
it comes down to I mean consoles are
highly optimizable and they do one thing
they're there to play games and I think
that that's what it comes down to it and
I think it's much like that rapid pack
math all right let's get a low tech low
about it as well involved in this we're
hearing a lot of things we're hearing
embedded SSD we're hearing Hardware a
chasing you know we haven't also up with
a thirteen teraflop GPU so uh Lord
Bowden like what do you feel just about
the sauce aspect like where you hit
material
yeah honestly I think monster kind of
nailed it is that really the the core
architecture of these next-gen consoles
is probably going to be pretty similar
and to his point when you're saying
secret sauce all it is is you know the
fine-tuning really yeah you know it's
it's secret sauce is a weird way to put
it but she's the CEO of AMD so I'll let
her be
but yeah i you know as Fonzie said it's
all about optimization and how could it
run the games and I'm at a place when I
heard or say that because you know the
rumors have been for a while now that
Microsoft's gonna bring anaconda and
it's gonna be you know stronger than ps5
we most of us have heard that and then
they start talking about things like a
km rate racing which you know I just was
a weird thing to again talk about on day
one um but uh what I find really
interesting I love to hear you guys
thoughts on this is you know a lot of
this technology that we're talking about
especially on Hardware ray-tracing
versus software ray-tracing and Nabi and
you know 7mm chip size and those types
of things that are being discussed in
this next-gen you know not only are they
priced heavy but some of these things
like Dion Hardware ray-tracing from a
console perspective would not only be
first-time things right but the timeline
to get those in production and mass
produce for a worldwide delivery by end
of next year or late next years they've
got to be cutting it close I don't think
those things are in production today
someone can correct me reading my tweets
[Laughter]
kind of written hardware perspective and
what we're gonna see with lockhart
versus anaconda right and Microsoft's
approach but there's some really
interesting stuff on there but it really
as you were talking about it's all about
computing it's all about data bandwidth
um and you know I think they're both
going to be heavily heavily optimized
we've gotten to a place with the ps4
original Xbox right there was the
pissing contest with Sony over the Xbox
and then the X came out and threw down
the hammer right and now we're at a
place where they're both in this arms
race which is great for us we benefit
right absolutely um but it's gonna be
really interesting but I think mods made
some really good points there just
before I give it to you King I just want
to ask mods and you'll about in
reference to a big point of contention
seems to be hard
air raid tracing right and I know you
made some points all about it in
reference to you know that the time for
delivery and obviously done making
cutting it close and then you know this
I'm hearing conflicted things some
people saying there's no way possible it
has to be kind of like on a software
level so like a lesser version of it you
know kind of like what's being
implemented now like today's video cars
like the older cards they can in theory
do you know ray tracing but not to the
level you know of a more advanced a
hardware so what do you guys think in
reference to the ray tracing aspect like
what aspect you think it might possibly
be anybody can ask their mom all right
for you to get a hardware enabled
hardware enabled GPU at this point in
time you're talking about it upwards of
eight hundred dollars right that's just
for the GPU so this you Sony fans right
now I got this very low oh I got I got
word myself properly I'm immortal
podcast and it's family friendly guys
that have this veil of secret sauce over
your eyes um
this is what's happening right you're
confusing what they want to do what they
can do and what they will do alright
these are the things that you're
confusing first what they want to do
they would love to give you Hardware ray
tracing they would love to be able to
click a button and Surrey working that's
not gonna happen
alright let's take that off the docket
that's done alright now let's go down to
this so-called secret sauce which is
software ray tracing now a lot of times
you got your engineers and your
programmers this sitting and they're
working together hand in hand during the
joint and they come up with a method
that is different from what other people
are using to get the same effects that
hardware will bring to you right kind of
aspects what's going yeah so once they
have that and they're able to display it
and you're able to trick the consumer
into believing that it's hot on a
hardware level but you're doing it
through software
then they hand us out to all that
studios this is your secret sauce this
is your ray tracing that is done through
software this is what you're gonna get
because it's cost effective and it's
giving you the close to the same effect
that you're gonna get instead of adding
extra costs to the system okay all right
now somebody said something about audio
ray tracing I do believe that I was
attacked this week in my um tweets I do
believe that you had it wrong now he
said will be ray tracing like an audio
listen Sony does not support Bilby at
most but they needed to come up with
their own audio solution alright so now
that you if you ever have Dolby Atmos
which is available and xbox one x times
oh and the regular Xbox right now as we
speak
and put it on you can hear sound above
below and on the sides right so when he
said that he actually said absolutely
nothing alright so now that you got your
audio ray tracing which will be on a
silicon level in the system
that's what you're gonna have audio chip
that is nice and dedicated that's in
there that every system comes with audio
chip Christopher bushes he said King
doesn't want to admit that pH 5 is gonna
have all those features the PS 5 was to
have those features count on the
Anaconda having the features as well I
mean yes but I really don't see anything
that the PS 5 gonna have that the
anaconda won't especially with all the
stuff I'm hearing about you know because
I mean in this community we hear things
right and behind the scenes I'm being
told certain things I'm not gonna repeat
it but anaconda should be substantially
more powerful than the PS 5 and if
that's to be true then if there's any
type of ray tracing cooked into whatever
the PS 5 with their chipsets or whatever
that'll be there for the Anaconda to is
at least as soothing about Sony because
they just did their kind of partial and
veil right and Microsoft's been quiet
but you got to think about from an AMD
perspect business perspective
Phil Spencer and Microsoft they're not
going to play around with AMD they they
have the muscle right from a business
perspective and there's already been
talk for a couple years now that Phil
Spencer the xbox engineers a Microsoft
and a bigger scale right or working with
AMD at this level so Franz is exactly
right and that's that's why I think and
we saw what club really a partial
document last we have which body yeah
yeah so I mean Microsoft is being very
clear that they're gonna run two
consoles and that anaconda is going to
be the performance leader in fact oh it
just you know yeah I mean they've said
it well I'm glad because you literally
transitioned into the second part which
is obviously I'm sorry can I add
something to it if that's gold yeah
sorry I'm that's kind of two things
really let's let's put right racing in
the back burner first of all about the
partnership I'm this partnership with
Sony now we already seen Microsoft
actually Phil Spencer at AMD stage
during was it the CES 2019 I think and
they were talking about great
partnership and stuff yes no it's not
like Microsoft is not there and they not
working with AMD and stuff right right
yeah so that's one thing another thing
is that not sure if you've heard but
Phil Spencer I think well that was like
two or three months ago he basically
said that whatever they going to be
doing with anaconda or or Lockhart you
know because obviously he couldn't go
into not too much into the details he
said that the the very same chips that
you will find in anaconda and probably
Lockhart are going to be the same chips
that going to be used in future X cloud
right so we're talking about these
blades right now what that but that's
that's interesting but what's even more
interesting is he said that they're
going to have like I don't know hundreds
or like thousands of these blades right
and someplace is going to be used for
gaming and he said that some of these
blades going to be used for professional
work clothes so my point is that the the
sheer amount of chips that
we'll be that Microsoft will be ordering
from AMD even if you think that let's
assume that next X was going to sell in
only 30 million
you know unit right they're going to
have even more of these chips order from
UD for the X file but the not only for
gaming and the eggs the whole Xcode
thing but also for like professional use
so whether that's AI and stuff so which
also brings me we're probably going to
continue later on that is that Microsoft
may go with a with a bit different path
with engineering these chips because
these chips going more for both what
you're going with
sorry a different secret sauce yeah yeah
if you think about it's like so they may
have a a bit differently engine used you
know chips because these chips will have
to will have to actually be good for
both gaming and professional workloads
okay let me um actually want to comment
on something here at shed real quick I
don't out the Lord face 23 became and
why she said it coming it coming for for
summing it from some of our guys they
said people keep saying anaconda will be
more powerful there was no proof of that
right now
just rumors from insider I know you've
been attacked on Twitter from a lot of
your reporting there's no proof but
Microsoft is said it name I mean Phil
Spencer has said it he said it last year
and that's why you can confuse but they
also you know the I'm trying to be
careful what I say here internal
document from the Xbox team then
highlights the Xbox scarlett strategy
which is Lockhart and anaconda says
absolutely clearly that anaconda is the
performance leader and will be the best
place to play games on the next
generation that's what the internal
markets are document says let me play
devil's advocate for the fans for the
favor is do they disagree now what what
do you say to those who say ok that is
the case and that they're saying that
but what if they say and that's more in
competition in reference to the locker
and I do would you say that um how would
you say that that Microsoft went up know
what Sony's doing so to speak that know
that the AMD relationship yeah so yeah I
mean again so and that's kind of touched
on it right you're talking about the
world powerhouse in Microsoft right I
mean they just are they're the world's
powerhouse in the computing space so to
think that they at least someone in
Microsoft doesn't know what Sony soon
with the PS 5 you're fooling yourself
they know what they know what they're
doing um and then just to be clear on
the document I'm referring to it clearly
says industry performance leader they're
not referencing long card because law
card an anaconda on this document are
separated as two different things right
channel and all of the internal art
excuse me not internal all of the kind
of documentation on specs that we've
seen right is that Lockhart again to
Matt's point Lockhart in anaconda are
gonna be very similar to from a
structure perspective it's just a
difference in some minor chipsets and
data bandwidth goals so yeah that's what
I would say and I just think you know
you're right I've been attacked pretty
heavily they comment so all I'll say at
this point is give it time no yeah
anybody who's said anything like that
has been attacked either on Twitter or
YouTube comments section it's crazy but
yeah like you said you hear a lot of
things and you know you just sigh die
people who are questioning this at this
point because Microsoft has vowed not to
have a console that's inferior and I
hear holding true to that that aside
though look it's all about the games at
the end of the day and the PS 5 is a day
one for me just because of those games
that we know what they're coming with
and and I can't wait as a console guy
yeah that's what I buy the PlayStation 4
is those exclusives those Naughty Dog
games and you know everything they got
going for it God of War Santa Monica has
done a fabulous job with that with that
series and now you look over to the
Anaconda and you're like well if they
have that power like right now you got
the X the most most powerful console I
own the X because well I want to play
I'm as a car
so guy I want to play you know the multi
plats on the best representation I can
outside of the PC space because every
time I say that PC guys get mad well buy
a PC then know I'm a console guy so the
X is where I play that T in a common
bonds this power so power does matter to
a lot of gamers like myself it does at
the end of the day bottom line it does
is that you know the funniest thing
about me me in territory my comment was
specifically says that the PS 5 based on
what we heard from mark Cerny
is going to be beyond what I expected so
that's a good thing and then next year
is going to be amazing for both
platforms yes and it got turned into
something like you know like I was
saying PS 5 it's gonna be terrible
that's not the case I think can be great
I'll buy it on day one like I do every
console that releases like and you know
I wasn't trying to start a debate but I
mean facts are facts one of them's gonna
be more powerful absolutely man
appreciate you standing on that shout
out to the super Chad deaf singer again
with the files which are this narrative
about Navi being exclusive stop it
big film walks in and gives AMD to check
AMD says yes sir flex to get the better
that signature right now well it's all
about the money bag though at the end of
the day I mean for these companies it's
about the money bag let me get to the
point all right AMD is the only winners
in all his war
yes oh very big bet on both sides I told
you guys just ain't sorry don't forget
don't forget about about Syria they will
be powering CD as well so they are
really the biggest winner mess that fuga
out of here we all know about your going
to be playing these CDI games let's talk
about AMD here for a second and I want
you guys to understand she's not gonna
go up on the stage and say yeah
PlayStation is going to be weaker no
what she needs to say is they have a
little secret sauce alright that's not
gay
you anything all right that's that's
just giving you a little in the window
like don't worry
all right trying to reassure the crowd
they have a hundred million active
PlayStation owners
ok they want that to translate into a
hundred million PlayStation 5 owners and
a right now I don't know how many
million Xbox owners there are but they
want that to translate into 50 million
Xbox owners all right the only people
they really don't care about they want
them to die out is Nintendo because they
use in video alright so now that you
understand AMD has a horse in all these
races no matter who wins or loses they
win all right no matter what they did
their big bank they own both so don't
think she's gonna go out and talk bad
about one and big up a next one she's
not all right it's going to get to the
point where you're gonna start
understanding and hearing we're training
your ears to hear buzzwords and
catchphrases to distract you being a K
all that stuff is nice it's fine alright
don't don't chase that dead demon that
dragon don't chase that what you have to
look is I'm gonna tell you now normally
the most powerful system isn't the best
system alright and in in the whole era
of video games it always boils down to
software and implementation of that
software to get to that hardware alright
so you can have two underpowered chips
inside a 16-bit console that are two
8-bit chips that give you great games
turbo graphics you have to understand
how they're going to use this power I'm
not telling you that PlayStation will
lose a battle because they are weaker
alright
they will continue to be exactly where
they are because of their software will
continue to carry them Microsoft is
trying to get to the point where they
can rely on their software
and have the horsepower to keep that
narrative going that's all explained
there if you remember early last year
Microsoft spent three bill and Sony
spent less than one why I'm suggesting
Carl is not Navi but is the next
generation graphics core and why
Microsoft is so confident about the
power law of Mars in the inside of a net
before it before yeah I mean this
there's some rumors but obviously
nothing really I mean nothing is
official obviously still the rumors but
there is this rumored basically talking
about the fact that Microsoft may use
the next-gen GPU from AMD now the
problem with this rumor is the the fact
that I mean Navi is not out yet right
and we are like right so I mean you know
unless they are developing both of these
architecture at the same time well maybe
that doesn't sound like very likely
unless we're talking about some form of
our custom chip that would use for
example Vega and Navi so basically
existing architecture and basically
borrow some new features from this next
generation you know AMD architecture but
as I said these are still rumors so yeah
absolutely
oh wow shout out to disuse ha ha did you
the father said don't let kings banter
and let you forget the fact that he is
going to eventually Oh solve some nice
on the bed to be safe but he won't let
this go Jake I love the fact that he's
actively been trolling me and I I do
appreciate it but remember I am Thanos
of this and these are people means yeah
you may think that you're gonna be
throwing your disk inside that
PlayStation you're gonna be back really
compatible you're going to put your disk
in is gonna say $4.95 there and it's
gonna be milling your knees I want them
FedEx with ice I wanna be high so you
can send your knees as well great savage
we have to look back at try to chat we
see you brother let us but what we got a
lot of tops to get into so on next
jump this off on the epics tour back in
the news again with another big
acquisition as a
psyonix the creator of rocket league
joins the epic store family they came
out of the statement and AMD I mean
actually am once again excuse me the PC
community is not happy with this
announcement especially when reading the
fine print so it looks like on epic game
it had to jump in front of epic are
games like to jump in front of it they
said basically there's no announced
plans to stop selling rocket League on
Steam rocky league remains available for
new purchase on Steam and long term
plans will be announced in the future
however this has got a lot in the
community to be upset because the
thought process is that eventually at
some point that it will maybe
potentially stop being sold so what
they're saying is they're still gonna
support the game if you have it on Steam
and that you know the nature of their
relationship I believe the other fine
print is they said they wanted uh they
said sonic said we want to clarify that
after today's news rocket leaves is an
available range available on Steam and
anyone who owns rocket League through
Steam can still play it and look forward
to continued support but again point of
contention after this deal is finalized
that it may not be available for
purchase so I want to bring this to the
laws I start with Lord I'm just a lot
more fine I'm very curious with more
funds um what do you think about this
whole epic store thing and um you know
where you at with this particular
acquisition yeah it's it's good you came
to me because I'm gonna have to go here
in a few minutes start my cast anyway I
just want to say that this whole epic
versus steam thing no look I haven't
really PC gamed in years
it's been some time and back then and
this was even before Steam ok so a long
time ago I would still buying those CDs
and putting them in the machine so
anyway you know I just think that the
whole thing the way I look at it is epic
is trying to make moves to get people
over to their their app or whatever it
is that you their launcher and it's
working because if you look at the sales
of these games that are coming out
people are buying them so
well people on Twitter and everything
getting all upset over this stuff
they're buying them on website I could
see the problems I could see the issues
that they have with the launcher the
epic launcher doesn't have a lot of
features that steam does and they really
want them to have that this whole
nonsense about the Chinese are spying on
them and stuff all right that was
debunked and and so they don't have that
to go on anymore but yeah they don't
have achievements they don't have forums
they don't have a review system and
that's all things you'd like to see in
these games and you know Steam has that
and and that's some of their biggest
gripes but at the end of the day people
are buying the games there and this is a
way for a company to come in and try to
scoop those players up by saying hey
we're gonna take this developer and that
developer and have these games exclusive
maybe for a short time maybe forever but
you're gonna come here to play those
games and that's what people are doing
at the end of the day so I think that's
that's basically it man
oh great point fun thank you for Johnny
I know you gotta go soon thank you for
that yeah get into it Oh before I get it
to live out it I'll shout out to our
point lord lemon 1:08 dragons TV with
the file on a super-tight
AMD has come out and said Sony and
Microsoft will have their own secret
sources and tell mods this is lemon jay
and friends that have realm so Maz Levin
wants to say what's up to you bro oh I
forgot to mention one thing there the
somebody at Epic was interviewed or
something and it and somebody was
telling me I didn't read the interview
so I don't know I could be having this
wrong he could have told me this and you
know and not been truthful but
apparently they're not really looking to
add those features either and you know
that is kind of you know not cool in a
way like I understand some of these
gripes that these Steam players have but
you know I don't like to see one company
dominate and monopolize a system you
know what I'm saying so like I like
competition for Steam
I think epic being there is a great
thing but they need to expand they need
to have those feature sets that you know
please these customers at the end of the
day all right and I need to be out with
that
picked up the call in snap-on's loop the
Lord's fight culture plug your podcast
man we go fight culture podcast will be
on so after the show guys come check us
out live if you missed the live
broadcast you can catch it right here on
YouTube by culture podcast and our RDX
Tuesdays 5:00 p.m. West Coast time
dealer gaming channel daily gaming salut
co s would salute D batch the whole crew
czaka Tim dog to new acquisitions salute
you guys and this show Fonz thank you
for picking up the call you man bro oh
wait family family you already know
salut bro and lord
um actually Lord Bowden let's get you in
on this this whole epic star it's a lot
of a lot of tension in there in the
Internet in the Twitterverse right now a
lot of nonsense this I don't know I
think vas gonna nailed it right I don't
like any monopolization and steam has
been a monopoly on PC gaming for a long
time now now to be fair right they offer
great deals they've they've expanded
steam tremendously since the first
launch right it's got a lot of
functionality like he was just talking
about but they need to be checked and
this is anything coming out with that
fortnight billions right and basically
just flexing and saying here here's our
money
we've got endless amounts of it right
now it's good and you know we're gonna
check steam and so they gave that
developer cut you know a much bigger cut
developers obviously we know where
they're gonna go right it's a money
absolutely I mean it's it's vicious but
it's business that's all it is at the
end of the day and and when you've got
publishers looking at their bottom line
and looking at their they're bored
sitting around the table saying what are
our stocks doing and you're you can't
make that decision to give away 15% of
your game profit mmm you just can't
yeah um I mean I've been in some of
those conversations they're gonna say
wait there's another option where we get
15% more revenue from the same game
found that's where you're going hmm you
don't have a decision here this that's
where you're going talk a bomb so I mean
that's that's what's happening and I you
know whether epics going
at the right way or not and you can
debate but the fact that they're doing
it and they're challenging Steen's I
think is a good thing honestly it's
finally someone to go to steam and say
hey you're not the only dog in town
exactly give the kid things ready bublik
but I want what I actually wanted what
about the comment that uh Tim Sweeney
said recently in reference to you know a
lot of backlash in ref you know whatever
tillers doing as far as the exclusive he
is saying that if um he said it I quote
he said if steam committed to a
permanent 80 percent revenue share for
all developers and publishers without
major strings attached
epic would hastily organized a retreat
from exclusives while honoring their
partner agreements and consider putting
their own games on Steam how do you feel
about that statement know about do you
hold him keys can you let's imagine for
a second you're in this you're a player
key player one at one of five or
whatever right in this battle and you
have the balls to come out and there the
statement like that you know what I mean
I mean he basically just went to Gabe
and all of everybody a valve and said
hey what's good there it is yeah it is
and he's basically calling their bluff
right that's what he's doing he's
basically saying I know you guys don't
want to do this so I'm gonna say if you
do it things will be this way but I know
you're not gonna do it so um I don't
know I think it's it's funny to watch
them fold I just I couldn't imagine
having that type of you know money and
funding and responsibility and
everything and just come out and make
statements like that
no no it's crazy to me I think it's fun
to watch them fold you know I mean cuz I
don't have a dog in the fight I'm kind
of with fawns I PC game for a while used
to build PCs and get really into it and
nowadays man I'm so busy and I'm older
and I just like turning on my console
and pliant um it's just a lot easier
nothing against PC game and that's just
for me so I don't have a dog in this
fight I really don't but I just find it
interesting to watch unfold absolutely
let's get a little King he's bubbling
right now Chester Morning Sun I see this
I said hey hey look at you guys look at
you guys y'all upset right now you mad
you big man
look at you all upset meaning your
feelings welcome to our world
whoa now you now you getting a taste of
what this console life is about you said
you don't like it we know if not all lay
down you play here or you play nowhere
hey what you gonna do you hate stores
now now you will have two apps you will
be in two places are you upset because
that the company said we will save money
over here so we ain't gonna put it over
there okay then you won't have to get
another library adequate what about the
people who say this is anti-consumer
restaurant you walk past everyday and
don't decide to put your money in there
I'm not gonna pay those guys I know I'm
gonna go to this place so you deciding
on what you want to eat where you want
to eat right in the same place it's the
same thing nothin is given to you that
you're not entitled to anything hmm you
wanna take to this place take your bucks
here if you want to take your bucks
here take your bucks here if you want to
eat in both places which I like to do I
like to go get french fries from Burger
King right in the McDonald's with my
burger sit down and eat and you can't
tell me I can't do that because I'm
doing it because I got my fries
remembers y'all make garbage fries like
these fries and I'm gonna sit here and
eat this fish sandwich because I don't
like it over there but I put money in
both places so you're both winning so
you're both gonna shut up and allow me
to eat my meal because I got a lot to
say to Budds what do you feel about the
whole arm epic store what epic store is
doing
acquisition of a studio man psionics in
do you feel or mass this is
anti-consumer I mean like I mean okay so
I'm a PC gamer as well and I play on PC
quite a bit right apart from consoles so
I mean for me it's really is just yet
another game launcher or should I say
you know Store launcher because I think
I've got like six on my desktop right so
I mean at the end of the day like for me
personally I don't care whether I will
start a game via Steam launcher original
launcher epic launcher battle net
launcher
actually let me check my desktop you
play now obviously if if if the rumors
of like you know spying by China stuff
if that was to be like true and stuff
well I would say that that's dangerous
and stuff right but other than that I
don't really have a problem with the
epic now obviously I get that people may
be like okay so epic is there but
there's no feature there's no like no
party-to-party chip or a party chart or
whatever right but I think that they
they kind of like released roadmap of
all these features and I think back like
the next six or so months the epic
stoller is going to be way way better
because I I did use epic story and it's
it's it's it's crop honestly yeah you
might not even mom you can he not even
resort the games your question right
when switch decides to give you no party
chat none of that stuff right and switch
decides they're not gonna care about
what you're talking about right I'm
gonna give you a company because you
know a lot of people it's gonna act like
this is unprecedented like they need to
give me this Nintendo has actually
showed you they don't need to give you a
damn thing they're gonna put this out
and they're gonna give you all I
remember they said they're gonna
announce they online and you said party
chat and stuff better be in it and what
happened right now and people I think
they got what 10 million
active subscribers to their online let's
see these companies don't care what
you're talking about
all right they already see people buying
the launcher they know you're gonna go
where the games is that when you're
playing in the corner where the headset
on and your mutant you can't talk to
your friends they don't care about you
and your buddies all right so as long as
you keep giving them money you keep
buying it from there
the only way they stop what they're
doing is stop putting money you're
saying send in the angry tweet but at
the same time you're clicking lunches at
the same time stealing my point came
about to going going home shout-out to
Lord Oh who's in there oh yeah boy
dear Rodriguez he says no top tech tank
top salute so let me give it background
here so we're clear let's go we had a
couple big cats right so this tattoo was
done in honor of my son and I had just
got it done and if you've had tattoos
you know it's a damn mess after you get
it right
and so you I couldn't at home wear a
shirt because it was a mess so I wore a
tank top on like two shows flex these
guys have not let me forget
[Laughter]
he says mods and I'm a [ __ ] said epic
realize you can't serve what you don't
have and forcing steam to change or be
left behind a la blockbuster vs. Netflix
and then the surge had some interesting
comments he said epic story service is
can't use where profanity that's the
issue so unless they get their profanity
together all the efforts the strong arm
will be in vain let me get at this man I
got to talk about this this isn't your
one-man listen shot I got a shout-out to
the pettiness of Lords sweetie here
despite being the most despised man
it'll say about a pc master race on the
neck man I mean you know all jokes aside
just like you know law-abiding you know
Aloma I've been only gaming on PC very
since last year on a high-end ring I
love it but I will always be a console
gamer at heart first now I got to admit
like I'm
I found all this outrage to be very
hilarious to me like I say like no hear
me I was like King we from that era when
like I had to Sega Genesis right and you
own and then King I'll never forget that
day he had the Japanese import version
of the Super NES f-zero and mode 7 for
the first term and I was like yo I gotta
have this I don't care but I was Sega
kid right I only I don't care what plan
I'll say I have to get the opposing
platform because my mind is blown like
this is amazing yes it did next as soon
as he came out right because all right
you gotta understand from my perspective
I had to Sagan I'm like oh this is great
so they told me a canal that I can pick
up the Super Famicom when it dropped
right so I went down that thing I spent
like four or five hundred give me give
me give me all this game
give me a crazy give me everything let's
go Thanks how do they got to the hell
man and I'm laying in my bed and I put
it on mm-hmm I said oh my god oh my god
oh my god this sound ship is crazy they
did graphics it's crazy so I called him
immediately it had to be like 7 a.m. in
the morning immediately because I got it
at 5 a.m. right called him a 7 a.m. so I
called him and he had our other cousin
come to us so they came over to the
house mm-hmm
I've never seen tears of why I gotta
leave his house now yeah it was so I was
like so terrassa I can't believe they're
doing this oh my God look at these
graphics like I've never seen anything
like that okay see what I'm trying to
say is look at the end of the day you go
where the games are you go into games or
that's just what it is now I know this
is not a one-to-one comparison and I'm
saying obviously what's what epic is
doing and I'm saying most likely you
know rocket League is gonna be removed
from Steam you know I'm saying I get it
I get it I hate the features I'm saying
yeah I hate x exclusive and I like the
last-minute nature is a little shady
with some of these deals I'm not I'm not
going
but here's the problem like like King
said like that loud vocal majority
against epic you know I'm saying it's
not stopping them like they're seeing
the success of tires like Metro Metro
Exodus and so like two and a half times
more then that's like did on thei they
seen on on the epic story
so all that childish review bombing is
not swayed where the majority of gamers
are going to get their favorite game
like so hey didn't love it epic knows
this man they go continue they got the
data they could continue that practice
practice so it's up to y'all to truly
vote with your wallet not review bomb
you know saying it showed that yo it's
up to steam now to kind of step up their
game right and and fight a little Lee
I'm saying to come back because
ultimately this is good in my opinion
long term for game is like epic is
overheating like you gone said they got
their fortnight money they got their war
chests and last point I want me shout
out to Lord Derrick Bradley CEO of
Aurora 44 studios and action we had a
more an ILP on 97 right and he talked to
us about the huge benefit of having
action on the epic story as well as like
the tremendous support they got and the
financial backing so in my mind I can't
say it since I consumer when the very
devs that create the games we love or
getting more of a revenue slit slit and
they can better brace for any impact of
a failed game because we all know what a
failed game you know I'm saying like
your studio could go under so that's
just where I'm at with it
you know I'll leave it to you guys to
finish this point up you know as far as
that but um it's very interesting to
watch to me Laura about it I think this
thing's very very interesting so that's
a great point about the dev and shout
out to them man Ashton was great game I
actually played that for backseat game
and funny enough but yeah I mean right
if the deaths you gotta go with the devs
and publishers are saying sometimes
those conflict but if the devs telling
you this was good for us and it's good
for us there's a lot of studios out
there that are one game away from
bankruptcy AB and so
Luke yeah they're not trying to take
that chance as I said man it's business
these guys it's a business what it is
he addict had to go but are we gonna
shoot his type of golf in he had a good
one man this is a good one it's talking
about games as a service and what he
wanted to kind of expand on was like you
know obviously we see see if these
what's going on and you know how they
continue to evolve but just in general
you know me we've seen stories like what
anthem and stuff like that what's going
on with them and they're kinda on the
flip side so just about games as a
service in general and if it's bad for
the industry so bad let's start with you
um what's your take on games of service
do you think it's bad for the industry
where do you reside on that I think it
can be done well it can be done poorly
just like most other things right you
look at something like so division two I
said I've been playing the hell out of
and I bought I'm a big looter shooter I
think I said that the start right so I
have a anthem I have division two and I
said before they both launch hey
Division two is gonna crush it just
because they had that foundation from
the first game and you kind of you knew
what massive entertainment was doing
because they communicate well right
we're not gonna talk about Bioware's
communication but you kind of knew that
so if I look at something like the
vision - and you see the package that
you get in that game at launch that's
where I think and the roadmap right this
one year one roadmap which is all free
from massive that's where I think game
as a service has its hits its stride
hits it's potential right because you're
giving players tens if not hundreds of
hours of gameplay from one game and they
can just continue to you know invest in
that world for a long time and I think
that's a great thing but then you look
at games like anthem you look at games
like fallout 76 you look at games like
that's Destiny's original launch there's
a lot of examples where a lot of
promises are made and that launch game
is just
there it's not even looking for what
they were talking about so and then then
you're invested what then you're
invested $60.00 in a game that is not
what was said to be and then you know I
this is just me speaking but III thought
Bungie had some [ __ ] audacity to
language sir sorry sorry sorry sorry
Oh God little good to come out and you
know then say well you know we highly
improved this game but to really play
everything in the game you gotta buy
this $40 expand no and then at that
point it which wasn't even part of the
season pass which I had you know I mean
so you get this first two expansions
which were nothing mm-hmm and then they
come out and say here's a $40 expansion
that really makes the king good and
you're like I could yeah well I don't
know I think it comes down to the devs
and publishers as always right if you
have a good Deb and they're not managed
by a poor publisher which I think anthem
suffered from because we saw I forgive
his name now but the CEO of EA Wilson
right yeah he came out last year and
said anthem will launch in our fiscal
year yeah and so what that says to stop
we're back to the stockholders because
that's what it comes down to is that you
know that game was gonna launch by March
period hell or high water come and they
can go to Wilson and say hey this is it
doesn't matter Matt we told the
stockholders this game's launch in
fiscal year glad you said no so that and
that's what happened and we see where we
are with anthem but then you know you
get the flip side I think Ubisoft has
been probably the pinnacle over the past
few years of games as a service man they
have we could talk forever right rainbow
succeed you got even for honor which
started off you know getting criticized
a lot that's still going strong you've
got wild lands are still supporting
Division two is a great example they're
just they're killing it with so
continued support for existing
franchises so I think it's down to
planning alright when you when you don't
really have a plan you you have to plan
for the
in the bag you don't always go in
looking for the good alright you always
got a plan for the bad because
eventually the bad will crop up right so
you got a plan for bugs you got a plan
for downtown you got a plan for server
things you have to plan for these things
so when they do happen you have a
strategy in place for you to make sure
that the game is not down long the bugs
is wiped out really quickly and you
understand that these guys once you have
speedrun guys that blow through games
that don't look at your story normally
your story will take about 40 hours of
story okay now let's look at it from the
other perspective of the speedrun guy
how long would it take for him to knock
that game out if he knocks it out in
three hours he's standing around doing
nothing complaining about your game you
have to keep him engaged right so I
always thought limits a games as a
service we're gonna talk about anthem
we're gonna talk about a failed game we
have to talk about the games that are
successful like his division took as a
Division one everybody was trying to
throw it in the bushes I thought it was
a good game you have to understand they
build on these things those roadmaps are
very important but you also have to be
flexible when the wrong happens the
wrong happen anthem and I hear it was
terrible all the way through I know it
didn't have a place to fit in I knew the
game wasn't going to sell how they
wanted it to sell because they were
pushing it to the boardroom right games
the service is a great thing it means to
be in something like a game pass and I'm
gonna keep telling you this the reason
why and a lot of people say well you
know King you can't put mediocre games
and a service and let it grow there no
what you're doing is you're cushioning
the fall alright you're giving them
airbags just in case something does go
wrong you don't jump in your car and say
it was the safest car in the world
forget the airbags the hell no right you
you sat there and said well you know let
me make sure that I get the maximum
amount of airbags in this car safety
ready 100% right you're not going to
anticipate in the crash but just in case
something goes wrong you don't die right
so you want to make sure that that game
is cushioned so it has a chance to grow
when they--when games as a service is
part of a service I
think that's the best thing we're all
taking a gamble when we go out to
purchase games you don't know that if
the game is gonna be fantastic or not on
any game even if it's not a game as a
service game you don't understand if
it's gonna be supported it's going to be
a good game you're going in with hopes
and dreams let me give you the flip
though King what about just to play
devil's advocate cuz right be honest
we're all most of us here I'm gonna ask
Mars in a minute but most of all say are
kind of like games of cirlewd a shooter
kind of guys right but I want to flip it
like what do you say to the argument
people to say you know what I'm not
feeling that a lot of these games are
launching like let's use fallout 76 for
example oaken broke in or in an
unfinished state where it's gonna evolve
and let's be honest as much as see if
these is having a resurgence right now
right see you thieves launch there was a
lot of people who are saying hey this is
boring there's nothing to do you know
you know kind of thing so what do you
say to those people that sometimes in
game services use as an excuse to launch
very light content and then add it on
later all right okay so you see I see a
thieves launched a regular and then
launched in game pass yes people that
weren't crying what was the game pass to
the people that were crying was the guys
that didn't have the cushion all right
so when it launches in game paths it
gets a chance to grow in terms of
something different now the fact that
anthem and I hope anthem does make it to
game pass the fact that anthem is out
there standing alone twisting in a win
without any support as far as you see in
devs leaving you're seeing people
leaving games launching broken is a new
trend it's new all right before we get a
cartridge and it's complete the game is
complete you got it
there was no add-on there was no
internet for you to download some DLC
something to save your game from being
crap if it was crap as it launched they
understood that it was gonna be crap
forever right so now you got a system
that they put in place that we agreed
upon because we keep purchasing these
broken games we are complicit in this I
want you to say it because a lot of you
guys are out here running around
screaming and those games come out broke
but if it's your favorite game no
favorite franchise you are purchasing
the game hoping for DLC to fix it
not doing that and complaining about
what happens next
that's the problem fair enough fair
enough we gonna get a lot of mods in on
its 86 watching a please hit that like
please hit that subscribe really trying
to give you guys quality content as much
as we can lord maza very curious I don't
I don't take you as a looter shooter
kind of guy and you're right I don't
replay a lot of the service you know
kind of games but I'm more of a
single-player kind of gamer right and I
like you know some multiplayer games
once for a while but like you know you
know quick thirty and might be up to now
our multiplayer session and and I'm
alright
but like I think it it all comes down to
the quality of the of the content
because like like with a single-player
game I guess that it's actually
sometimes it's actually more difficult
to fix something right with the
single-player game while with you know a
game some service I mean there's if
you've got like a good plan for next for
you know for some for you know future
right I mean even if if you obviously
which is not great if you actually come
up with a game that is broken on or some
got some problems you can fix it right
but my problem is that like Destiny's
great example I mean you know these the
mean I'd already want to blame
developers I guess it's more about
publishers they just milking the gamers
right because like somebody said like if
you if you if you I think King said that
that if you release a broken game or
basically again without any content and
you are hoping that basically you know
gamers going to have to pay like an
additional $60 to actually get some
content and some fixes I mean that's not
fair real alright so you know I mean
that's my take inert so I guess like at
the end of the day if you release a good
game with a you know steady you know an
income of new content all the time
I mean yeah you probably opt for success
if not then you you you know a
developer's going to struggle although
as I said I mean if they deliver like
free content new content updates and
stuff and we've seen like rain rain
books each I think was one of them I
mean it's still one of the you know
mostly played games you know on all
platforms right and and and it struggled
at the beginning right hmm yeah yeah
share the slo-mo set mods are you saying
bungees price-gouging their community
what's up mods I'm I'm actually
interested I'm actually interested to
see what Bungie is going to come up with
after the you know split with you know
Activision so you know this is going to
be a real test for Bungie whether that
was Activision telling them to milk
gamers or was it like yeah let's do it
they put out content they've been
putting out content if you follow the
last word with Lockhart Melanie Montez
they go into the fact that there's a lot
of content I just logged into destiny
the other day and I saw a crap ton of
content that was there that I'd never
had before
um yes a lot of it is switched around or
kinda in the same name but they're
trying to get the Eleni trying to get
their footing they understand what's
going on and how the division to change
their fortunes and they're trying to do
the same thing with older software
alright but the new software going
forward we're gonna see the the true
test of Bungie and the new software
going forward with destiny 3 which is
inevitable it's coming JD game again oh
thank you brother with this $5 super
chat if co DS was released today how
would each member of the panel rate it
with its current content level um good
question um I think right now from from
what I'm hearing this content update is
really strong I'm hearing good things
about I haven't got a chance to play it
I heard they have actually had like some
type of story I give it a man quest base
stuff and then um I was listening to
that also said they got they have is
another mode don't know if it's like a
arena mode or something like arena yeah
it's a PvP mode yeah yes yeah and I've
heard good things I'm curious to go back
to it know about it I'll let you
you played it or not the update no no so
we're aware actually can we play a dance
played a ton of it
and we used to play man that game is
just hilarious it's a really unique game
it's hard to compare it to anything else
because you know it's just really unique
but man when you play with like three
other buddies and you're just you know
messing around on the ship and sailing
and fighting it's hilarious so yeah I
think with this new update giving you
the PvP standalone option and the tall
tales shores of gold is what the
single-player thing is which is supposed
to be like 10 to 15 hours with like
puzzles they call it kind of like a
Goonies an Indiana Jones mix oh come
which those two hit us right away right
Goonies Indiana Jones so yeah I'm
looking forward to playing and I think
you for release with all these updates
today it would have been a much
different conversation for sure yeah and
you'll be case of stoppage at nine Kings
stop at King said you fraud and King you
gonna say that I'm fraud in right now
right his level of what he said was with
all the content you got right now yeah
that's exactly what he said so maybe for
you it's not a nine but again I'm gonna
tell you right now you're you know what
be honest with you never entered my head
oh and I hope I don't enter your head
when you gonna purchase a game and Blake
King go put that floor alert don't do
that
alright don't don't purchase your games
hoping to please me cuz they're not
gonna happen but you see I keep Sega
classics on right here because these are
Sega boys in this room so Sega classics
has been running on so if you actually
you look over you actually see a lot of
good Sega games that you probably would
not read the 10 but I I'm wale about it
man this is tough for me because clearly
I'm biased I like leadership you know
salute to my brethren
lordy pontus last word on all looter
shooters we do every Friday that show
but um listen I'm addicted to games like
you know that that's the music division
even anthems and soon Borland so I can
definitely see this is what I'll say
because yeah I know how I feel about
Battle Royale
right so there's like I couldn't
see some mumble rap tendencies with
copying certain things to catch a wave
you know to be I see certain companies
you know trying to get on that games as
a service kind of trend and I get it you
know I'm saying you know the thing is
it's like look right now some of them
are launching very light on features and
I think with the selling point that it's
gonna evolve it's gonna get better and I
think like King said like unless you are
free to pray or in a games a service
like game pass like most gamers are not
gonna stick around into your game
decides they wants to get better because
they like people the community you got
to get a community what they want so I
think it's three things
this is Minister lorkhan you know three
things that you need to do if you're a
little shooter that you I mean that you
gotta kind of get involved with your
game the first is transparency like like
my balance I think you have to be
transparent you gotta let the community
know you know what's going on with the
updates why these patches and why these
decisions that you're doing a being made
you know no one needs to be guessing I'm
looking at you destiny think what's
going on in your game too
you got to be consistent you know saying
like these games are tremendous time
sync so in a player basically eaten up
like candy so you got to have a strong
live team laughter you gotta be strong
that's willing that's always gonna be
able to deliver that consistent playing
content and then the third thing it's
kind of similar the number two but it's
role map right and you see in that kind
of anthem like even if it's just a
bullet point right
hey in November this raid is coming all
this you know month we go and launch
this activity like no one wants to play
a perceived dead game with no hope on
the horizon right so that to me is the
key like if you do that with your base
you're communicating you're consistent
you have a roadmap and give me an honest
a transparent then I think you can be
fine you know I'm saying so just me
that's what I got on it but we will move
on if anyone got anything else um last
two will fly doodies because we're
running a little bit over on Borderlands
3 the reveal lot of people hype about
what's going on and obviously then also
some statements from lord randy
pitchford
vs game informer we will get into that
but let's talk about the game
and then we'll talk about the second
part little Bowden are you uh
Borderlands guy and do you see the
gameplay reveal and then what do you
think about Randy Pitchford statement
recovering yeah
die hard Borderlands in fact my whole
family we play um yeah my my stepson
who's in the Marines out in Hawaii
diehard borderlands guy hundreds of
hours must my son my youngest son who's
here still here plays it my wife my wife
even plays it with us so die hard man
I've got um got the collectors I got the
loot chest right behind the camera right
there from Borderlands 2
but yeah I've got two of the diamond
loot chests editions pre-ordered I'm all
over it all over it so I love what I've
seen I've watched all the reveals I
watch extra footage I love it it's kind
of like they went into my head and said
okay take Borderlands to take keep all
the good make a lot of things 2019 ready
and here you go and that's exactly what
they've done with us epoxies was you
there no I didn't make it out oh no I've
never been to a pax I've heard great
things
Oh God you gotta go do yeah he said I
hear someone mentioned the king of
looter shooters Borderlands three is
coming for its title Oh coming really uh
so what what about the these statements
with what's going on with the Michael
Chad actually you know what Game
Informer had reported you know in
reference it would be cosmetic items of
microtransactions the evil were did
Randy put have some things to say right
he had an eighteen tweet barrage CEO of
a company Twitter with your eighteen if
I'm a worker at that company I'm like
good god shut up you know like I just
anyway I don't know hey he said he's an
awkward guy you know I mean he just is
he's one of those guys that you you kind
of wonder why they put him there's got
to be someone who could present better
than Randy at these shows but yeah I
mean you know I guess we get the point
he was trying to make it's not nefarious
Luke content it's not loot bah
is there's not you're not having to
spend all this money to get things that
are going to help you get loot or level
up or anything so you know we all
understand that but regardless if you're
just going on pure definition being able
to buy cosmetic items is a micro
transaction as to his letter to the law
yeah so I mean is what it is he could
have been clear about it we kind of see
what he meant but he needs to accept
that buying cosmetics is still a micro
transaction one way or another
fair enough Lord mods are you a
Borderlands fan and also what did you
think about Randy Pitchford statements
versus Game Informer yeah I did play
quite a lot of Borderlands I'm actually
playing those games again on PC so yes
I'm looking forward to Borderlands yeah
as for the V's you know mr. pitchfork
statement I mean I have already seen all
his tweets and stuff ah but I think he
it was something to do with a you know
loot boxes and dogs and stuff so did he
did he just deny it first and then he
said like yeah but there may be can like
that yeah I kind of yeah I've seen
something like that come on
yeah I mean he went in on a game of my
heart he said that's not yeah but but I
think he there then said that yet but
you will find something in the game and
stuff right I mean like I like when
developers publishers and everything are
really like clear and they are honest
right and clearly there's something
stinking going on over here so you know
I mean I would be surprised if if there
was nothing in the game in terms like
loot boxes and some microtransactions
that kind of stuff I mean because
clearly we don't all mow a lot of these
games actually do that right now and
then publishing stuff so yeah but I
don't I don't necessarily like when the
gamers are being miss misled if you know
what I mean right
no absolutely after I already sent Lord
King
Borderlands revealed we were there in
the building when it was bad nice
jealous
it was an exercise in dexterity and you
know I really respect the CEO for doing
his hardware it was it was it was
beautiful speed it was beautiful that's
that's what happens you know you can't
plan for the wrong but when the wrong
happens do you have a plan yeah I really
respect him and I'm purchasing the game
off of that strength and what he did and
how he feels for his team we didn't we
did see something genuine there right
yeah yeah yeah and that was that was
good to see you can see I think at one
point he was like almost tearing up yeah
because you know they probably been
working on years for this so that was
good to see I absolutely give you that
and the fact that you know the
excitement of the fans to watch because
you know they had those frame hiccups
when they first played it which we're
driving his team crazy and when they
finally got to go and you can see how
excited he was for the game in the frame
which was cool mm-hmm so what do you
feel about this holder statement you
know and I'm him going at GameInformer
about them reporting that there are
cosmetics in the game and him kind of
bobbing only well you understand he's a
very passionate person so I don't really
you know that's like petting a porcupine
and getting mad at the stick you you
can't really do that thing you can't
really expect something different be
careful you talk about a lot of these
people take this stuff seriously this is
a game that's highly anticipated and
they don't want no negativity attached
to it before the game comes out they
want to reach a broader audience
they understand that before when
Borderlands came out there wasn't no
Destiny's there wasn't no divisions
alright there wasn't no anthems they
don't want any negative stigma attached
to this game at all they want this game
to be able to stand on his own they
wanted to be able to fit in alright they
I don't want you to understand anthem
really lost because it was not a place
for it to fit in alright so they need
Borderlands to be able to galvanize
their community right those people are
going to purchase and they need them to
reach critical mass where it reaches out
to other people that don't play
Borderlands
and they need that word-of-mouth to
spread nowadays a bad tweet will will
sink tens of thousands of purchases so I
fill him I understand why he would say
it and being there like I said before if
he was watching there if you were there
you understand the level of individual
that you're dealing with and his his
team worked so hard on this and he's
gonna go to bat for his squad yeah I
understand the sentiment I mean I jump
into I mean about the game like I said
I'm kind of late to borderlands but I
did play to I really enjoyed it this
seems to be a tremendous improvement
game looks great I like the smart loot
system cuz none that loop ninja and
stuff and people spreading take you get
now they kind of got that part up to
speed with like a destiny and stuff and
to be honest or about and like I got
into the game late but you don't really
connected me to Borderlands it's
actually tales of the boiling how late
the tell-tale get shot to dizzy he knows
what's going on shout out the Attic
Oakland that is the most hilarious
telltale game ever play it really put me
in the world of Borderlands and I found
out that one of the characters I believe
his name is Rhys right yeah he's gonna
be in three so I'm like I'm a fan of
that cattle I would laugh I gave me me
laugh out loud like four times okay so
I'm feeling that world and all that now
far as the statements you know you know
I'm kind of I'm in the middle I'm kind
of wit looking and I'm kind of Whittle
about know certain things because it's
like you know it's a tough situation I'm
a huge fan game before me like I've been
rocking with them since like they look
pattern scenes became stop remember with
you you know body you know nothing like
that i I've went on those guys I got
tremendous respect for you know I mean
salute to those guys and they report you
know I mean so um you know as far as far
as Randy I don't know him personally see
like cool guy we saw him at PAX you know
super passionate you know salute to him
but like King said keeping his composure
when all things are going wrong doing
that an issue boy lens revealed I mean I
fell for the guy on stage you know the
guy was doing magic tricks he was doing
over stuff kind of I honestly don't
think I've seen anyone in that
circumstance for that to happen and that
Matt listen that place is packed for
people coming to just see you and that
and for that to happen and it didn't
happen once
it didn't happen twice it happened three
times he had to keep his composure and
me and Kent talked about at the show
like could you imagine ID wheel a big
reveal and all his things keep going
wrong and I salute him on that aspect
but you know here's the thing all being
said he was out of pocket goodbye friend
he was out of pocket coming again before
cuz it's like I know what you're saying
King like the evil dirty little word
Michael transactions once that gets out
right- changing attached to the game I
get it
I admit it but it is what it is if your
game got it you got it right now yeah
and a lot of things can happen as Sony
is proof positive to the fact that up to
an hour before the show they went and
switched everything yeah oh it was
launched it with DRM and it was going
all that stuff that y'all did not want
to hear no outfit till that point they
can snatch it out okay here's the I feel
but here's the thing no I got I know a
lot of people don't like him but I got a
salute Lord Jesus Rider
with the epic clap back did you see the
clap back no he put out a tweet and he
said um regarding the same type of
statements Randy made about battleborn
- when battleborn was launched when he
came out and they I think I believe
Kotaku one of those guys are kind of the
first report' like hey this is gonna go
free to play and in typical fashion and
really jump out on sweater - his Twitter
fingers no this is not happening you
know I'm saying this is BS why would
someone put a horrid story like that and
yeah he plays I was told about a
reckless story about battleborn being
free to play and then literally you know
somebody don't don't announce my wedding
before I announce my wedding don't do
that I get it somebody need to snatch
his cell phone away from you got caught
again
I got so shreya was ready when he saw
what was going on with this four lanes
three he's over you okay you put it out
and it is what it is he waveform and I'm
saying so it is what it is listen I you
know I agree I think I don't think he's
an evil guy based on my everyone buddy
definitely speaks a little yeah I think
King Nelly he's really passionate
yeah he's danced a frou squad yeah and
those are good things right but he
should said it before he's an eccentric
kind of guy yeah Game Informer you know
and II kind of made the statement which
was factual of course naturally the way
they rode it causing controversy right
yeah but Randy came back and and I think
that's where I struggled because of the
type of guy he is I don't mind you you
absolutely stick up for your team right
stick up their development you don't
want that label as you said you know but
the way he went about it I think yeah I
think coming back making a huge charade
about it does more damage in the long
run than just coming back you know being
matter of fact and say look there's
nothing you can buy on day one we're
debating putting some cosmetics only
they'll never be any loot chest they'll
never be any pay for performance or pay
for upgrade type things I'm sorry if I
was unclear and leave it at that
yeah keep a professional to feelings I
agree but that type of guy 2kings point
that we do miss that's all I got next
thing let's just wrap up we got your
last joint don't worry about it oh we
can drop that into the bushes we can
talk about it because it's an ongoing
thing that you guys we don't need to
it's not a rapid PAC thing but that's
something that I just so you don't want
to roll out and just roll into the
bushes I think that we're gonna dig into
a 12o so we'll get out of here with the
pole new I'll people this week with the
recent announcement of the epic store
crying psionics and the possibility of
rocket League being removed from Steam
new purchase only at a later date in
opinion is this move anti-consumer by
epic towards gamers the choices are a no
stop crying develop it more revenue and
you still play rocket League
both steam and the epic store B yes
forcing temporary exclusives on an
inferior platform last-minute is shady
see I don't care until epic storm forces
me to bend the knee on my favorite
exclusive that is those are the question
please wrap the IOP boat when it goes up
on twitter tomorrow Lord as Li Bao ting
oh my man it's been a great time I
really appreciate it
absolutely man fresh from the hockey
game because we lost three times yeah
one goal which you know we were joking
about it before right if we would have
scored at the end it would have gone to
overtime I would have been even more
late my absolute pleasure to have you in
the row man where can the fine people
find you what do you have going on yeah
so always check out season game and I
appreciate it um yeah Porcia power I'm
Porsha power everywhere well so and a
half in forever that's my live name PSA
and Twitter kind of everywhere so coming
up no I'm getting into Xbox fan fest in
a week and it's so enjoying smooth that
your first one fan fest yes I was at the
Xbox conference last year but I didn't
get into Fan Fest last year so me and
Bert actually both go into that and be
at the conference obviously and you know
being there in e3 for the whole week so
just oh we got a new brother we got yeah
I was telling I don't know if he told
King but King last year I was standing
in line to get into the Xbox Theatre and
I saw you guys oh you were in line like
just in front of me but I didn't you
know we never spoken I wasn't gonna walk
up and just actually encourage that if
you see me talk to me I actually love
that stuff but this year
we definitely had to ensure you
definitely gonna come out to the
compound we always you know chop it up
we always go out for dinner and stuff
like that you are going to love fan fest
it is a real treat for those people that
get a chance to go to that treat it is
definitely whatever dessert that you
ever loved that's exactly what it's
gonna be for you and I want you to soak
it up I want you to make sure that you
take a lot of pictures remember the
moments to record everything talk and
greet everyone because when you're there
you're absolutely amongst family you're
going to truly enjoy yourself it's going
to be a high point of your trip
absolutely Lord mods are fellow resident
amyl and Lord of lords of gaming dotnet
how doing sir awaken if I people find
what's going on yeah thank you very much
for having me again so I'm always you
know up for some tech talk construction
games well because at the end of the day
it's all about content and power doesn't
matter yeah but yeah thanks a lot for
you know having me you know great panel
and great guests you know great Doc's as
always you know gaming and stuff and app
you can find me on youtube obviously
mods gaming and Twitter mods gaming PL
so yeah brilliant
thanks a lot thanks for coming in Lomas
again last minute holding us down
tremendous articles man love the tech
focus really appreciate what you do for
more more more more are coming because I
have some you know family situation that
was traveling recently a little bit as
well we hit like a long weekend here in
Portland as well so haven't had too much
time but yeah or Maurice Cummings and
much appreciated so we always look out
for those articles been great content so
well yeah but I also want to shout out
Lord Fiennes who came through like I
said he's doing fine coach podcast
please check him out for your MMA combat
kicks with Lord meds you know there's a
family to the realm and of course Lord
saw and Lord I actually had to go here
to start to work and Louis are we will
see you next Sunday hopefully brother
hope everything is ok with you in the
realm
or king where can I find people find you
what's going on sir oh it is so on
Wednesdays you definitely can catch me
at a Kos King statues now on what you
see right there submitted in the
background is throw a brick of brimstone
if you want more information on that
statue you want a little bit background
into it if you saw Avengers in game you
want to understand the dual world thing
of the hammers and you want to see
Milner right over there Stormbreaker
right next to him those are broken down
those are prop replicas those are not
toys and will definitely bash your head
in
yeah very serious um they're very heavy
I mean so you tune into Kos it's up on
the YouTube channel it's also at Lords a
game of dotnet also um yeah boy is in
his bag alright so this is a movie
studio 16 I know it's not the top notch
you guys but leave me alone I'm flexing
my little video muscles and I'm trying
to bring you better content so when you
get combat talk with the king or you get
a Kos that's up and we also still
working on our K King on how to get that
format game we should we move our
cameras are we allowed to legally show
oh no you can see that stuff right there
that's not me actually planning you
don't that's green screen or whatever
the hell it is I can actually plausibly
deny in a court of law
if my feet is held to the fire but
listen man I want you guys to continue
to cultivate your your passion as you
can see you see Lords Ainsley's there
with his statues and his war he
meticulously put that wall together it's
a beautiful war I loved his whole setup
I want you guys to never lose that
passion never lose that glow these
statues and these are toys are here
these are things that keep you grounded
in your youth don't ever forget that joy
and passion that you have you know we're
talking about depression earlier I want
you to stay in your safe and happy zone
and remember that time you first opened
up your console or you first opened up
your toy get
back to those moments that bring you joy
because a lot of times you out here
working and you and your grind and your
neck grinding stand that grind it will
wear you down that's why it's called a
grind you got to get back to your base
get to good things enjoy your life make
sure you take time out and smell the
roses well and definitely a reflection
of Lord Ainsley Bowden's article that's
the good in gaming right that's what
it's about at the end of the day yeah
man look at me to here you already know
we can finally make sure you hit that
like subscribe notification getting all
that good stuff
Lord carboxyl we'll have the audio up on
all your favorite platform Spotify
iTunes all that good stuff
Chad thank you man you guys were
absolutely spectacular links will be in
description on next three weeks man I
believe coming strong we got your
prediction favorite of us I will get you
container stand on that we'll let you
know but we're gonna have some
heavy-hitter panels just like today it
wasn't and we're looking to really talk
about what's going on these press
conference we will get you the
information as soon as we possibly can
also please for your gaming news please
check out Lords of gaming dotnet
obviously CEO of minds on here he's
putting out good content and also people
if they're interested if you're just
looking to get in the game of course
writing news or any of that kind of
stuff please reach out to myself reach
out to lore dizzy in the chat or also
the Lords gaming net twitter handle is
obviously we're definitely still looking
for aspiring scribes in the realm shout
out to extreme team you already know who
you are so now though l-boogie MJ is the
boss old-school style
Lord de la Poste she'll be coming back
soon and like you said King Kos is up
tremendous stats who's please King is
putting tremendous content and nothing
gotta give me credit you're giving back
story on comic book versions of the
character the true origin versus the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and I think
that is really cool to educate people on
the differences you know even educate me
on when my fraudulent so you know even
though I have my issues with a game we
did certain things about things being
true to comic even though it wasn't
infinity gonna we gonna go there but
he's killing it out there and again if
the looter shooter fan please follow the
last word
myself any party every Friday your
destiny in your division your anthem
what's going on all these little
shooters that is our passion that is
what we do everybody enjoy your Sunday
and on that no peace